just cause i got chickpeas don't mean
it's harmless just saying
[Music]
hi my name is michael hi my name is
george i'm michael's brother
hi i am nancy i am michael's mom and i
am an arab
today i and my family are trying dessert
hummus
for me a good hummus has a slight pull
it's not too watery you know a little
bit of lemon a little bit of garlic
the tayna the sesame paste good quality
chickpeas
i have always scoffed at dessert hummus
i see it in the stores
it seems alien to me i mean i do like
chocolate so
a strawberry one i never thought of
mixing any kind of chocolate with
homeless
personally i think it's an abomination
but i'm also
very intrigued so we're gonna try this
today
so today we have dark chocolate we have
strawberry hummus and then we have
chocolate cherry cheesecake hummus
first i'm gonna try the dark chocolate
hummus well definitely looks like
frosting or like
a mousse almost like a chocolate mousse
it kind of looks like a frosting
it's not moving um and usually hummus
moves even if it's refrigerated so
that's a little bit odd to me
it's very thick thicker than i thought
it would be
hmm
oh i mean texture's kind of funny
better than i uh thought it was gonna be
i'm not mad at it to be honest i
definitely was expecting more chickpea
flavor
i thought that it was not going to
strike a good balance the initial taste
just like regular homeless
i get like an aftertaste of chocolate i
think i tasted chickpeas they come
through more than the chocolate
does i guess you could use it with like
fruits maybe
i feel like it's almost there i just
need it to be a little bit more
movable but i don't think i would serve
it well
that's a lie if i were making a
charcuterie board i would probably put
this on there i feel like it's good
because it's not too sweet it has a
jenny say quoi
would you actually serve that together
no i won't
i will not serve it to my guest so i'm
sorry
[Laughter]
the next flavor we're going to try is
chocolate cherry
cheesecake hummus when i saw this in the
supermarket one i was
baffled two i was in trees because i was
like oh
okay and actually this is the hummus
that kind of inspired this video because
this is so
out of the blue that it just felt like
yeah i need to try this i love
cheesecake factory i like the raspberry
chocolate cheesecake so i'm hoping this
will kind of give me that
taste and that feel this one definitely
smells like a dessert like it smells
like a pudding
oh that smells really good
this one you can smell the chocolate
more in it than you could in the dark
one actually
oh my god i'm rocking with that that's
really good
i like that one that actually really
surprises me
this one tastes more of a dessert than
the dark chocolate
it tastes like a moose like you don't
really taste the chickpeas
you can taste the chocolate you can
taste the cherry the description of it
is right the name of it is right
wow
even my dog likes it that's how good it
is it's not as
thick as the original one the dark
chocolate one
where it's still dippable this is a
really good hummus can i get another
cookie please
this is really good yeah like if you put
that in a cake form
put the crumbles on the bottom and just
dump this put it in the freezer to
solidify it a little bit
and serve it as cheesecake i wouldn't be
able to tell the difference here we have
michael's famous
strawberry hummus this is my son's
creation michael
so i'm curious what it's gonna taste
like
i have not tried this i did not try it
while i was making it but basically
you use a regular hummus recipe
chickpeas garlic olive oil tahini
and then i added a pound of strawberries
into it
so we're gonna see how it tastes
i'm hoping that the strawberry flavor
actually comes through in it
doesn't look as thick as the chocolate
one it smells refreshing it smells like
something
that i would eat if i was hanging out
outside it is you can also scoop it
and it's easy to dip in there so this
one actually this one's got a pretty
nice texture not obviously a hummus
texture
[Music]
oh my god
okay not bad at all this is really not
good
i'm sorry i flopped on the texture
actually it's good
it's not bad and i'm not just saying
that you can taste the tana coming
through in that too
chickpeas not as much as the dark
chocolate one has almost like a yogurt
taste to it actually
kind of tastes like a smoothie almost
which i was not expecting yeah i would
serve this to my friends
they'd be a little confused i wouldn't
tell them it was homeless i'd just say
hey try this and then let them
as they oh what is this oh it's homeless
i would serve this like on a picnic
maybe oh okay let me set the scene
maybe i'm like going on a date and i'm
like oh hey i made the strawberry hummus
for you
[Music]
i might serve it to guests but not tell
them that it's strawberry i
must let them think it's just some type
of strawberry dip to go with their
fruits
would you tell them that michael made it
oh yeah
i'm not gonna tell my dad
would i consider these hummuses no
i guess the chickpea factor technically
makes them a hummus but
no my opinion has changed on dessert
almost i
really didn't think i would enjoy any of
them if i'm being honest
would you consider this anonymous no
i would not consider any of these at
home just because i got chickpeas don't
mean it's homos
just saying and what makes you an expert
considering i'm arab and i make it all
the time and i learn from the best
i think i'm good on this
you